- So, wait, we just had the Oscars Sunday.
- Yeah, I know.
- So you didn't go,
I know, I heard, but
like, did you watch it?
What your favorite moment?
I did watch it, I was in a
restaurant actually watching it.
They had it up on the
thing, so that was great
to watch that.
- Yeah.
Anything happen that you love?
- I cried when Brendan
Fraser got the award.
- Oh, it's so cool.
- I cried.
- He did such an incredible job.
(audience applauding)
- Yeah, I worked with Brendan, you know,
quite a few years ago on
a film called Inkheart
and he is such a lovely person.
I think you've had him on your show.
- Yeah, yeah, I've him a couple times.
We love him, yeah.
- I'm sure you, you know
what a beautiful man he is.
He's a magical man, I think.
And he was clearly very, very moved.
It was a huge moment for him.
So, it was the right person for me.
The way he responded to it,
I just found it very moving.
It was the highlight for
me of the whole show.
- I love that when you're
rooting for someone
'cause you really believe
in like what they're-
either them, or their
project, whatever it may be,
and then they win.
That's a really good feeling
for everyone involved.
- Yeah, it's great.
It's great.
- Yeah.